you have an after the credit scene it's
a little bit not it's after the main
credits but not after the whole credits
talk a little bit about how that
specifically came about and let's talk
with that yeah well dad that's like when
he said that was last thing to be put in
the movie you know that was because he
went back and forth a hundred times
nobody knew what to do you know where
they the studio or Martin well you would
put it in or not and we did from those
like eight or ten test screenings with
rescreen it with and without all the
time and and eventually by screening it
without the audience felt like they
needed some kind of closure with with
you know with one of the characters and
that's what we we put it back in you
know yeah really close to the title not
like in a Marvel movie after the credits
because we it's not a superhero movie so
so that's why we decided to put it in
just to have that closure and you know
who knows maybe you know movie
successful there might be another one
well what I want to know is well first
of all when did you actually film that
was it during the actual shoot no no
that was that was a we shot that in the
reshoot so it was actually after our
first screening of the director's cut
that we yeah we saw yeah we have to fill
in these storylines so that was a
decision that we made and actually
during because we only had 65 shooting
days there were some scenes that we
didn't have time to shoot and we knew
that we were going to shoot that in
additional photography so we had already
planned the days that we were going to
shoot new stuff and that's what that
idea came about like a-alice Judas
triads because nobody was sure whether
or not we had to put that in a movie
sure was there an idea that you almost
did for the after the credits or was it
always that scene in that jail cell well
there was an idea to do like something
with humor you know we had some of the
the jokes and we did that actually it's
a joke with Martin the airplane we put
that like a little bit later so it was
always an idea to that some of the jokes
that we had to cut or make sure he could
put something humoristic at the end but
not necessarily a scene it did that that
scene was was the only new thing that we
came up
the editing I think I'm sure you're
gonna agree with this but I think almost
every movie can benefit from additional
photography after the first edit and
after the first test screening because
you learn what you need it's really hard
to get it all on the on the shoot yeah
you know that the the rich should change
the movie so that's uh it's when you
start to move in you start to shoot you
you you never know 100% what the movie
is gonna be yeah so after the shoot you
see all the yeah all the all the things
you you all the story beats you need and
it was not a lot but it changed that
little stuff and for us I mean all the
directors that are really geniuses they
can do it right away without any ratio
it's pitch perfect from the start but
we're not on that level of genius yes or
maybe we'll never be but our movies we
did in Belgium we always had reshoots
and Richards there's something you don't
do in Belgium there's no money for it
but we always do it like with small crew
and we steal some shots and it's because
in the Edit it's as if the movie has its
own soul and tells you what it wants to
be so if it was to be a love story yeah
and you wanted to do a lot of action and
stuff no you're gonna have to shoot some
more love scenes but but also with with
this movie specifically and you've
touched on this this is a very unusual
tone it has to have action it has to
have comedy has to have drama and it's
about figuring out the balance of those
three things yeah it's not one thing
which I think is maybe a little easier
to shoot on its first try yeah you know
and exactly exactly and that's also you
know sometimes we had like an action
sequence and it never works and they
just realize yeah but there's only
action there's nothing of character in
that scene so you shoot some extra
characters scenes in the reshoots and
then the whole action sequence start to
work and that's what what the editing
what to movie what the test audience
tells you basically